GENERAL MANAGER.
ALEX DID NOT WORK HO
--
>> PATRICK: IN THE HAVE BEEN AB
UP WITH THE AND HE WILL CHIPPAT
IT ROTATION
THERE, BY
DO MISSED IT.
AND HE RETRIEVES, STREAK TONIGH
AND NOW HE CARRIES THERE.
AND
IT, BUT HE TRIED TO BAKE ENTIRE.
BACKIN THE YEAR, GOOD THE BOARD
CAUFIELD NOTU WATCHING OUR
FEET ARE NOT, BUT A LITTLE
POSITIVE JUJU DOWN TTO KEY.
TO THE FRONT OF THE NET,
LOOKING  ANTICIPATING THE PUCK
GOING OVER, ATURE WISELY.
AND THAT FORWARD, GOES TO SURE Y
WORD HIT HIM.
>> TO HIT THEM IT BACK, THE
ONE TIMER,OFBACK, MURPHY, AND E
TAKEN .
>> OFFSIDE
SHORTHANDED SITUATION.
SCORED AGAINST THE COUPLE TIMES
HALL OF THE
DRAW.
HERE IT  THEIR OWN. HE SHOT, JU
OF SENT TO THEIS THE DECK COMPLY
OFF BORING.
HAGEL THROWS HIS ARMS ] AN